welcome back to new rockstars everybody
this is the big question the show that
gives you too much information
about time travel in the marvel
cinematic universe and how maybe the
reason so few people do it
is that the tva sucks more than traffic
school my name is mt
and here today is eric voss my brother
from another mother how you doing eric
i'm doing good empty i'm so glad we have
an excuse to talk about time travel i
secretly want every big question episode
to be one about time travel
it's amazing and we did a whole like
thing uh
hector navarro our good friend and i did
this uh big episode about time travel
back in august of 2020 and now that like
loki is here it's kind of revising some
of the rules of time travel
also i got uh tenets time travel logic
all wrong so we need to do an update
nmt so glad we could do it
me too i'm a huge fan of time travel
deck time travel is
my [ __ ] but i know that time travel is
even more your [ __ ] so i'm glad
that you are here for this question or
for this video anyway now trailers for
the newest disney plus show loki have
indicated that the mcu is returning to
one of their favorite
narrative devices time travel because in
the latest trailer we get a glimpse of
the prime mcu timeline with many branch
timelines
shooting off of it so this has us
wondering how does
the tva and loki change the rules of
time travel
in the mcu eric all right mt i got you
covered
uh i got you covered until some point in
the future in which
i will be completely wrong we'll just go
back in time and fix it so if it's not
fixed right now
it means that i was correct right if
we're using that version of time travel
exactly uh i get to talk about my types
oh my types
yes what is your type eric tell me your
type oh you'll you'll hear my type oh i
can't wait to tell you my type
um but first i got to tell you about the
time variance authority the tva this is
the bureaucratic organization in the
marvel universe
tasked with keeping the pure timeline
intact that's going to keep
order within the multiverse of timelines
and make sure that no one gets away with
too much time medline they're time cops
but also like time lawyers and time dmv
desk workers
and time whatever mike wazowski
did you fill out your time paperwork
time traveling was asking
yeah that's what they are major
corporate heads over at the tva
now in the comics the tva's base of
operations is this area called the null
time zone it's a dimension that exists
outside the normal boundaries of space
and time
and actually in one of the trailers
mobius and mobius says well time passes
differently here in the tda
wow wow that was impressive that was a
really good impression
he says it just like that and that means
they're in the null time zone
uh while according to our eager uh
according to our eagerness to make
things what we want them to be in our
head
some more rules of this it appears that
they use elevator style portals to
travel to different points in the main
timeline that's kind of cool aesthetic
choice
major really cool i love the way the
portals look
there it goes it's so great
now the loki variant that we're
following in the show branched off from
the prime timeline when he stole the
tesseract the space stone and escaped
post battle in new york in 2012.
thanks to the actions of the time
traveling avengers who are in the middle
of that time heist
so let me quickly explain the the eight
types of time travel according to me
that's gonna take you back to that video
uh so type one
is what i call it time travel that's
basically
the vast majority of time travel stories
where anything goes
it's there's some kind of magical goopy
device whether it's a
delorean or a hot tub or
a phone booth uh fixing history there's
something that happened in the past that
they want to change
um back to the future is a classic
example of that
but then back to the future part two we
get a new type of type travel that is
called branch reality
time travel type two uh this is where
changes of the past
don't just kind of like affect the
future automatically
but rather split the timeline into a
multiverse of different timelines
remember doc brown drawing the 1985 b
so it's kind of different rules of time
travel now and that's what
hulk was trying to explain to scott lang
and rohde
of like no when you you have a new
future now it's a different timeline
so back to the future is a bunch of
[ __ ] it tends to be
when they start trying to be smart about
time travel let's type two
okay type three is what we call time
dilation this is where characters
move through forward in time at a
different speed
they can't go back in time so we see
this in interstellar flight of the
navigator
uh there's other places this shows up
type 4
is what we call this always happens
time travel this is where screenwriters
try to get real clever with it
uh it's where time is always the way it
was on a predestined loop
like things are the way they are this
unusual world is oh because some future
time traveler actually went back
without me noticing and just made things
the way they are
so uh everything is kind of justified by
the act of time travel
terminator the reason why john connor
has to lead a resistance where skynet
technology evolves into this artificial
intelligence
is because time travel happened to
prevent that to begin with
uh harry potter prisoner of azkaban the
third one
it was all like wait how did i get hit
in the head by the back of this thing oh
it's because the future you did that to
get your attention so that fudge didn't
catch you
and then they just never bring it up
again and they never bring it and then
the
creepy implication of this is there is
no free will
because things happen not because your
choices but because you are destined to
do them
it's complicated uh and by the way we
learned that christopher nolan's tenet
follows the this always happened
predestination theory
of uh everything that happens even
though they go reversal in time they use
these temporal pincers
things are the way they are because
people have looped back in the future to
set them
that way that's just the rules of it um
c in the future is what we call type
five that's just the kind of classic one
where characters can look ahead in the
future and they change their actions to
affect the future so charleston's a
christmas carol minority report
you know that's a raven of course
[Applause]
[Music]
but is it really time travel the your
consciousness kind of gets projected in
the future but arguably not time travel
per se
um now groundhog day is type six that's
where characters are stuck in a time
loop and they keep reliving the same day
or the same
year or they get as far as they can
before they have to loot back
palm springs uh live die repeat edge of
tomorrow
they're using this more and more a
russian doll uh does that
um and then uh type seven is my type
oh so okay unstuck mind this is where
characters uh
displace their consciousness forward and
backward in time and then relive their
history
okay so logan does this and x-men days
of future past
um that's consciousness displacements
unstuck time famously
it was slaughterhouse five that really
was like the first time people like whoa
this is a way you can do time travel
kurt vonnegut uh does where billy
pilgrim jumps around in time
uh desmond and lost does this and that
was
uh made a lot of references to
slaughterhouse five when they did that
and lost
uh and then type eight might be
one of the more complicated ones and i
call it unstuck body
because it's kind of like characters are
moving backwards through time
but they're able to control their
actions and use the reversing time
to their advantage and affect change uh
so
there are examples of this the one i
like to use is primer because
it's kind of like characters go in a box
and their bodies get de-aged
their bodies are unstuck in time and
they kind of loop back and they're able
to change
things but primer is also like a fusion
of like a
branch timeline um groundhog daytime
loop
um but i like to refer to it as unstuck
body because what's creepy about it is
it's the closest to time travel real
life
theoretical physicists have come up with
where they're able to prove that
certain particles theoretically can be
de-aged on the excess of time
which is just creepy to think about do
they make that in lotion form because i
would love to get some
de-aging going on here uh that'd be
great
too much hope eric it depends what
you're using the lotion for
into leave it there
yes uh it's not a multiple use lotion
please uh
just be careful where you apply it you
don't want a baby penis that's
not
[Laughter]
okay um so those are the eight types and
until now
every time we've seen time travel in the
marvel cinematic universe it's kind of
fallen into a different category they've
been very
inconsistent so uh the doctor strange
movie in 2016.
it kind of starts with uh some unstuck
body time reversal
in hong kong with type 8 that's where dr
strange like uses the reassembling
buildings to like trap people inside of
fish tanks and stuff it's a great
sequence
that was so cool you know christopher
nolan just watched that he's like i
could do this as a whole movie
that makes no sense and then uh but then
they also famously use groundhog day
style time loops when he's battling
dormammu in the dark dimensions like i
come here to bargain kind of his version
i could do this all day
that was type six and then uh avengers
infinity war showed uh dr strange seeing
the future type 5
when he looked ahead to the 14 million
605 possible outcomes
uh and then we get avengers end game
which blows open time travel in the mcu
of course
uh it starts with this kind of branch
actually starts a time dilation
right because scott lang would time
dilate in the uh quantum realm
so it's type three but then uh they go
into branch timeline time travel type
two that's what hulk is kind of
explaining
but they also do a bit of unstuck body
where scott de-ages into a baby
uh and type eight it's like a pro basket
it really is
uh but then it ends up in kind of a mix
of type one
time travel and type four this always
happen time travel it really depends on
how you interpret old cap's return in
the final scene
now the screenwriters claim that old cap
was in the background of the mcu the
whole time
and that everything we've seen has
occurred because that's how old cap
let it play out which is insane to think
about
yeah which is why the russos disagree
with it and they're like no he just went
to an alternate timeline like hulk said
he's just in an alternate history
he was he didn't let 911 happen yeah
that'd be real sketchy if he just let
all those terrible things happen
yeah so as is the case with most time
travel stories we're kind of left with
just [ __ ] it
uh and that's kind of where loki seems
to be hovering
uh between that and branch timeline
because
branch timeline is kind of the logic
they're sticking with
mobius's tva monitor shows that uh
flowing timeline and it breaks off into
branches as you said mt
and uh loki is labeled variant l1130
and he's just one of many branch reality
loki's
created by the initial break uh from
when he escaped in 2012.
even um tom hiddleston said as much she
said that like the title logo refers to
it's all about identity and there's just
like different versions of this person
that you're gonna see
uh and uh by escaping on that path this
loki variant was able to bypass the
historical path that we saw
the prime loki follow in the dark world
and ragnarok and infinity war
and now all these different branches
refer to several different other loki's
that we're going to see
president loki db kubiloki you know
whoever it is now
what's important about mobius and
mobius's visual example is that it
matches
the ancient one's branch timeline
description to
banner and in game you remember this
empty yeah she goes whoosh
and like the gold's line goes all the
way into the distance and then
yep she does the graphic it's a
wonderful graphic flicks the stone
yeah oh it's so great and any time uh a
complicated
explanation matches some other
complicated explanation of semantic
universes like yes we have some answers
now
um it's kind of like the tva using the
same visual metaphors as the wizards
it's kind of like
the nerds and the larpers agreeing on
the same pizza topping
pepperoni and pineapple an objective
truth of the perfect topping combo
unless are you willing to fight me on
that because i can do this all day when
it comes to performance
i mean i'm all about the pineapple on
pizza so you know
that's just where i'm at okay so
uh we are kind of left with the three
rules of this explanation of timelines
in the mcu
eric time travel causes the timeline to
break into
parallel alternate timelines what we
will refer to as the multiverse
rule two those breaks can only occur
when an infinity stone is displaced from
its place in history
and not returned so cap clipped a lot of
those branches when he returned the
stones but loki by stealing the space
stone
from that timeline it took the space
stone out of it
and it created a new alternate timeline
which also might tell us that
sub rule a that the space stone in this
timeline might get lost or stolen in
loki
uh and b that all the other alternate
loki's we see
might have also stolen the tesseract or
the scepter
from its place in history and or the
power stone
or the time stone or something else and
kind of caused all these other loki's to
split off in their own way in fact
maybe someone stealing the time stone is
how we get further chaos
because that person has a different form
of time magic
okay i like that and also this got me
thinking about
you know remember the power stone in
guardians of the galaxy that was
locked up so like i wonder if the reason
why it was locked up like that was
because of
maybe loki time traveling shenanigans or
they just wanted to lock it down in
history who knows
exactly uh and that idea of magic brings
us to our third rule rule three
this all works everything we know about
time travel
in the mcu is magic not science
so it didn't really make sense when hulk
tried to explain it to
rhodey or to scott it only made sense
when the ancient one
at that point in history the sorcerer's
supreme gave us
some confirmation and was able to speak
authoritatively on it
um you could argue that magic is
essentially
science humans do not yet understand
according to the asgardians
so it's all kind of the same thing but
it looks like going forward they're
going to use the language of magic and
not
like science fiction planck scale epr
paradox
that might be how humans try to talk
about it but really it's only going to
make sense in terms of magic which
which makes sense for the mcu because i
feel like once you say something's magic
it's just easier for people to just
digest and understand and accept
so like they're making these movies for
just the regular layman so it's just
yeah that's magic whatever
you get it you get it idiot stop
questioning that
stupid i'm not sure the science really
supports that
magic but that idea of sorcery may be
why
loki in particular was chosen to help
the tva fix this time crisis because he
is a sorcerer he's a wizard without a
hat
he uh trained in magic by friega and as
guardian witch
it wasn't just an insult she owns it
she's a witch she's a witch she loves
being a witch she loved being a witch
until she was murdered
by an elf um sad times
sad types look at me
witch
since we're now completing time travel
with magic in the mcu
all of this may just kind of descend
into that category
uh because loki seems to be following
shows like rick and morty and doctor who
and those shows
totally embrace absurdism with their
sci-fi rules
uh there is some logic to it and in fact
rick and morty had a rule for a long
time of never doing
time travel but then the writers
eventually just kind of caved on it
and then they did one time travel
episode so far uh
season four episode five that's when a
snake planet
invents time travel and then it ends up
going into
terminator rules where uh like
there's a predestined closed loop of
morty and rick's future selves looping
back on that timeline
and they do a little easter egg where
they plant their ship early in the
episode to show that the future cells
are just
waiting for time to catch up uh so that
ended up being kind of a type four this
always happened
thing i freaking love rick and morty
when they do stuff like that it's so
good
it's amazing and i bring it up because
the show runner on rick and morty's mike
waldron who is a rick and morty writer
and it seems to be they might be going
in that direction for loki
from two crucial details that you can
find in trailer footage
that they're gonna be doing kind of a
this always happened type four structure
for loki
the first clue is that tva timeline
monitor we've been talking about where
you see loki's
uh l1130 branch is really the one in the
middle and then as it extends you can
see various other branches to the left
and to the right of it extending as well
which means that loki's branch caused
ripple effects
after it in the historical timeline but
also somehow
before it happened so we can conclude
from that that loki's branch
inevitably led to some other future time
traveler
who looped back and caused other
disruptions that had already happened in
history
dang this is about to be some
complicated show dude it's gonna be fun
we're gonna have a lot of fun explaining
it we're doing the best
that we can and that brings us to our
second detail
db cooper so db cooper
already exists in our real world history
he was a mystery hijacker in 1971 who
jumped out of a plane with 200
000 dollars and he was never found this
show is kind of suggesting that d.d
cooper was actually
loki the whole time and do it
this series may be saying that this and
plenty of other historical mysteries
were actually just the doing of the god
of mischief's time meddling in the show
in other words this always happened and
it happened because of loki
dang is the reason why i'm depressed
because of loki probably yes
everything bad is because of loki 911
loki kennedy
loki january 6th loki
me stubbing my toe loki watch that what
the [ __ ] out
you just that makes more sense like
somehow loki farted too hard and the
earth got tipped off its rotation and a
revolution around the sun
but you've ruined time loki now we need
february 29th thanks man
okay okay so in conclusion empty
it's still a little soon to know exactly
how loki's gonna change the rules but we
already know so far
that it's going to skew the mcu into a
one of a couple different types of time
travel
and it's going to be doing the very
complicated dramatic tenet slash
uh prisoner of azkaban slash
predestination
slash terminator style where it's uh
insane to talk about
everything wrong in the world that we've
always asked questions every plot hole
potentially in the mcu
whether it's why is it don cheadle now
why is it ruffalo now
why did spiderman homecoming had that
eight years later time card it was all
loki's fault
exactly which i love
they could just wreck on all their
mistakes like yeah i was looking i just
don't even worry about it
so really uh while you could say endgame
showed us the door to multiversal
timeline themes to you was loki who had
to walk through it
and i'm so excited to see him do that
thank you for that
like all those riveting explanations of
all the types and i'm gonna be looking
closely for all the different types in
logan like
what types are you doing what are you
gonna do there loki
[Music]
focusing i will not rest until
everyone just starts using the types uh
the type code uh just kind of commonly
like
like when people were comments like oh
so this is like a terminator they're
like no dude type four come on watch the
new york city
honestly i want the types introduced in
dating apps so like you could just find
a partner by the type of time travel
that they like what type of time
traveler are you
i'm stuck time they're like oh you're
unstuck mind i'm unstuck body this isn't
gonna work this isn't gonna work
sorry i mean and one guy's like i'm just
a sticky body
[Laughter]
anybody want a sticky body ew no curtis
get out of here
oh i can i'm stuck to my chair
well thank you eric that was an amazing
explanation and we are going to dive
into our bite size questions next but
first
we gotta hear a word from the amazing
people that help make big question
possible
people like mint mobile big wireless
providers
love to trick us with a catch so when i
heard that mint mobile offers premium
wireless service starting at just 15
bucks a month i wondered
where the catch was going to be but good
news everyone there is
zero catch there it does not exist mint
mobile's secret sauce
is that they are the first company to
sell wireless service
online only by cutting out retail stores
there is no
crazy overhead costs that get passed
down to you in the form of
mystery fees disgusting but instead mint
passes those savings on
to you here at new rockstars philip has
switched to mint mobile and he
loves it he kept his phone and just
swapped out the sim card and has good or
better service as he had before at a
fraction of the cost
and all plans come with unlimited talk
and text plus high speed data
delivered on the nation's largest 5g
network use your own phone with any mint
mobile plan
and keep your same phone number which is
super convenient and if you're not 100
satisfied mint mobile has a seven day
money back guarantee so there's no risk
just go for it to get your new
wireless plan for just 15 bucks a month
and get the plan shipped to your door
for free
go to mintmobile.com bigq that is mint
mobile.com
big q cut your wireless bill to 15 bucks
a month at mintmobile.com
big q oh that sounds like a great deal
mt but i got a great deal for you
our sponsor masterclass masterclass lets
you learn from the world's
best minds anytime anywhere and at your
own pace learn how to act from natalie
portman
or how to dj from quest love or improve
your storytelling skills from neil
gaiman
with over 100 classes from a range of
world-class instructors
that thing you've always wanted to do is
closer than you think
now new rockstars we have been digging
into the business strategy and
leadership class
from disney ceo bob iger sadly he
doesn't go into how you two can buy
lucasfilm and marvel to become the
biggest entertainment giant in the world
but he does go into negotiation and
strategy stuff and that's still really
cool
master class is accessible on your phone
web or smart tv each class is broken out
into individual video lessons usually
around 10 minutes long
members can explore at their own pace
and each class is supported by
downloadable materials like lessons
and recipes oh yeah i didn't even
mention you can take a cooking class
from gordon ramsay or wolfgang puck
you can find all available classes at
masterclass.com
i highly recommend you check it out get
unlimited access to
every master class and as a big question
fan you can get 15
off an annual membership go to
masterclass.com
big question that's masterclass.com
big question for 15 off masterclass
masterclass
mastery of class so you're saying that i
can learn from gordon ramsay without the
yelling at me
i'm in there might be some yelling
involved i can't guarantee he won't yell
he gets animated the guy gets excited
about cooking you know
i mean all right then i guess that's
more more of an authentic experience
than yelling so all right so what is our
bite size question eric ah my bite size
question for you
mt uh so i want to know the exact value
of the stolen artwork that we see in
sharon carter's gallery and the falcon
the winner soldier
episode three wow well that is a great
question eric uh because there is a lot
of really expensive art
in that place i can't believe we're all
dancing around it but
why not it's mad report there's no rules
uh right right so when we meet up with
sharon carter in falcon winter soldier
she's still on the run
for multiple government agencies after
the shenanigans and helping cap in
falcon during the events of civil war
now
to keep herself afloat she's been
dealing in stolen artwork as we all do
when we're on the run
we only get a brief glimpse at some of
the collection
but after going through the episode
frame by frame we've been able to put a
value
on those pieces that we did see in the
episode nice now okay
first before the party we can see a full
suit of medieval armor and traditional
roman helmet
with the red plume or galea it's hard to
identify
exactly what these pieces are but if we
look at the similar artifacts from that
time period
we can estimate the following now let's
take a look at the suit of armor a rare
full suit of armor was recently valued
at
and twenty eight thousand five hundred
dollars to eight hundred seventy nine
thousand nine hundred dollars for a
southern bees auction
we can assume that the armor in sharon's
collection would be rare and valuable
but we can be conservative and listed at
like six hundred thousand
dollars okay still pretty good this was
really nice
all right good start and then the roman
gaelia of course there is a range
value for this type of piece depending
on the quality of the item and the
intricacies of the piece
but in 2010 a very rare and intricate
roman helmet sold for about
3.6 million dollars at a christie's
auction
that is wow yeah it's worth
more than my life no no empty
easily worth more than my life eric
easily we can cobble together more money
than that for your life
we will george bailey your life we can't
fully see the piece here but the metal
work from the back at least looks
impressive
now again let's be conservative and list
this at about
1.8 million dollars okay so half of what
it's sold for okay
yeah which is still pretty good it's
still really good yeah
now let's go to the party where zemo is
laying down the moves you know what i'm
saying because we have artwork there
that we could
identify now the great way the katagawa
uh which is a wood block print by
hokusai which is valued at fifty one
thousand five hundred dollars to
seventy seven thousand five hundred
dollars that's it that's a big one
they should pay more for that they
should really do that because that's a
classic piece of art and we got some van
gogh at the party with a van gogh
self-portrait from 1889
um and this piece sold for 71.5 million
dollars at a christie's
auction in 1998 which means that the
value in today's dollars would be around
like 115
million dollars pretty much double that
oh well not no that's not double at all
1.5 times that maybe yeah
yeah like 1.5 times that um it's
probably worth more but we'll just leave
it at that because we're not art
collectors here
whoa we're not i've been we're only our
thieves eric
we don't want to click oh that's right
if you feel like you're not a collector
yeah you can steal it but we just sell
it we just don't think about it where's
the certificate of authenticity
yeah then we have woman with a parasol
madame monet and her son
a painting by claude monet now a similar
famous monet painting called haystacks
sold at an auction in 2019
for about 110.7 million dollars
so i would say that we could probably
value this at
around that same price as well oh my god
arts so much
money and then we have the rehearsal of
the ballet on stage
oscar de ga from 1874 and a similar
degas painting of dancers was valued at
48 million dollars in
1999 which is about like 75 million
dollars
today and it would probably be worth a
lot less if zemo actually gets too close
and touches it
which he did he did with his sweaty
dance fingers
you touched it hey he got close he got
real close i think
zemo's two he's too classy but he's also
too curious so he's
he gets real close but he doesn't get
too close he's a toucher yeah he's a
toucher
zebo's definitely a toucher he's just
you didn't ask for that painting's
consent zemo
you see this guy at the party bounce
them out yeah he's
gonna be touching all your paintings bro
don't don't trust zemo he'll be all up
on your mona lisa
you know what i mean painting where on
yourself did zemo touch you
yeah we might be having to cut that out
and then we have the young woman of the
people by amadeo
modigliani bonjourno
and paintings by this artist have sold
for 40
to 170 million dollars so let us
conservatively estimate this at around
100 million dollars wow okay
and of course we have the head of a
peasant girl by cashmere
cernovich malevich i'm so sorry if i
said your name terribly wrong
yeah he i don't think he might and
paintings by this artist have sold for
60 million to 85 million dollars so on
the table we can see that there are
three bids
and it's currently at six million one
hundred thousand
dollars so it's possible that this art
is going for a much lower price than our
world value which means that maybe the
post world just values aren't less than
we do maybe we're just making a lot
easier than them
they've had to live practically for five
years so like you know what do we need
do we need to spend this money on
art since there was half people around
to even appreciate the art maybe the
value is down you know
and finally there is portrait of a young
man by renaissance artist
rafael and this painting dates back to
the 16th century and is actually thought
to be a self-portrait of raphael himself
which is very weird because he does not
look like a ninja turtle but we shall
let that slide take him out there's a
lot of historical significance to this
painting
as it was stolen by nazis when they
invaded poland in world war
ii it is still yet to be recovered and
according to some art market specialists
if found the painting itself would be
worth in excess
of 100 million us dollars today
right now we gotta find it empty what
are we doing making youtube videos
sharon has got the painting the painting
has been found
well if sharon has it it we she doesn't
appreciate it
she doesn't need it she has a high town
penthouse where
we're in the semen we're in a blue
dungeon just at very ends of a very long
hallway that's blue
hey bro what's going on hey anyway
we're not allowed to get close to each
other oh they they kept us apart because
we were just uh
cuddling at work too much we were we
were goofing around we were cuddling and
they said you too
long haul we are rising and cuddling
enough of that hey
cut it out it's your fault
so just these pieces alone would give
sharon carter of madripore
at least 563
million dollars worth of artistic assets
eric and that's just the arts that we
were able to see in the show
she's probably got over a billion
dollars worth of most likely but good
god
that is a classy a well-to-do woman i
don't know why she's complaining about
not being able to see her dad boo hoo
you got a monet
and she did that somehow uh she might
have been there for two years but then
she's gone for five
and then she's back there for six months
and is able she could buy an
island exactly like that's an amazing
work
work ethic if like for six months you're
just hustling you got all those
paintings
wow she's a hard worker that's sharon
carter
always hustling i mean you got a lot of
time on your hands when you're on the
run from the government apparently
that's right
that's right thank you mt for that
answer that uh clarified a lot of things
and brought up way more questions
it makes me far more confused about her
character now yes uh it's all super
complicated stuff
but you know with
time travel and art it's not gonna be
easy now it is time of the show where we
do our thing
with the box of scraps
scraps questions
now today's box of scraps question is do
you have
any funny club slash bar stories and
have you danced as well
as zemo eric do you have any cool club
stories
i believe i might have told a story in a
past big question about when my pants
ripped during apple bottom jeans at a
party
so i won't you have to go find that uh
episode i can't remember what episode it
was but my pants ripped because i went
to low low low low low
and uh there was video of it that my
buddy sent me later
uh but the story that comes to mind
right now um
okay so i have this weird thing about
karaoke where i
don't want to do it unless i know
everyone in the room
because uh i've just had a couple bad
experiences with karaoke
um but i love it i love watching it i
love going out with friends and watching
them do it
um but uh so there was this like it was
several years ago it must have been
because it was a friend's
um i think it was a wrap party for a
show she worked on or a movie she worked
on and they rented out this big
bar and it's like this a bar with like
multiple parts to it
uh it's just like one of these places
that like they ran out for
big parties like that for big studio
parties uh or it might have been an
emmy's party or something like that when
i used to work on a show
anyway um part of one room was devoted
just for karaoke and there was like a
big dance floor
uh and i was there for her really i was
like her guest
i was there for like a bunch of people i
knew some of the people there
but uh most of the people i didn't work
with them so i wasn't
i didn't really know them and i got real
drunk because it was open bar it was
drinks for free so i mean
you should i mean oh yeah uh and uh
so i was getting real drunk and then
like uh she was like oh we should sing
we should do a karaoke song
what song do you want to put down and i
was real loud i was real drunk and i was
like
you know what you need you need to write
down
you write you go up there you go up
there and you tell
them that you we are going to sing
lady gaga star is born oh she's like
what am i like a star is born
stars barn and i think i was trying to
say shallow maybe from
a star is born because i'm like oh this
would be a cool duet and then like man
people loved that song at that time so
she went up there and i was like yes
thank you
and uh you know it was a real long wait
list for karaoke
so everyone's just kind of dancing and
drinking i was getting drunker
uh and i'd even forgotten that i'd said
that and then she comes back up to me
and she goes hey we're up next and i was
like
huh she's like we're up next for karaoke
i put down what you said
lady gaga born this way and i was like
wait hold on what born this way
and then suddenly i was like oh no
because look i love lady gaga born this
way i think it's a great song
um but i realized i was i just read the
room and i'm like these people don't
know me and if i try to do this
uh it's gonna look like i'm making fun
of it it's gonna look like i'm making
fun of lady gaga's gay anthem
and i don't want to look like i'm making
fun of it like i don't know these people
don't know me i don't know them
if it was just like a root full of
people i know i would have been okay
with it and even looking back i probably
just should have done it i could have
crushed it
but i was just like oh okay and she
turned her back and i
ran to the bathroom oh wait you just you
didn't do it
i didn't oh my goodness so i was just
like waiting in there i was like
and they're like do you need help sir
i'm like me alone i'm fine um
and then i waited you know enough time
for the song to change over and i was
like okay okay i'm just gonna leave this
now i'm gonna leave this party so
as i made it back and i was in one of
the room i couldn't even hear what song
was playing i couldn't hear if it was
done or not
but i kind of made my way back through
to that room
and the music was
[Music]
bruce springsteen's born to run
so there was a second miscommunication
between
this woman and the dj where he thought
she wanted bruce springsteen's porn to
run
which for her totally out of her range
she's i don't think she was a big bruce
springsteen fan
so she was like
[Music]
and she was like bottoming out she
couldn't hit it meanwhile
i love spring scenes born to run i was
born to run
shoving my way through the crowd
drunkenly i'm like i can do it
i can't do this
but the crowd was like into it singing
the song back to her trying to get her
into it because the crowd like whoever
sings
born to run for uh for a karaoke
everyone else is just singing gaga songs
and they're like yeah
wow one two three four like they were
getting so into
it i was like that could be me
i'm so stupid and afterwards she's like
where did you go and i was like i got
sick
[Laughter]
well now if she's watching this now she
knows the truth no she knows
that's a lesson to you if you get
brought up to do karaoke whatever the
song is just go for it and sell it
and the crowd will be with you the truth
is though la is what ruined karaoke for
me because in l.a everyone's a freaking
amazing singer and they'll go up there
and rock the place
it's not like everywhere else where
people are just like giving it their all
and having fun and ellie it's like
oh you're an actual broadway talented
it's like singing at 54 and below in new
york like everyone's like an amazing
singer
and it gives you some impossible like oh
i just wanted to have fun and sing
tequila
i guess that's not gonna cut it
yo [ __ ] bad sing however you want
wherever you want because
if if like if your voice isn't super
good then that
is a commodity like that's what people
want to see because if everyone has a
good voice then who cares but if your
voice is just
average or like not great then that's
fine too like it's just a fun time
whatever
thank you mt uh what about you have you
ever uh
uh been in a zemo position well i don't
have a whole lot of um
clubbing experience as i was a loser in
college
i find that hard to believe no i'm just
kidding i just didn't really go out that
much in college but when i did go out
when my friends
finally dragged me from my uh doctor who
in adventure time
um dorm room um where i would just watch
those shows
um i remember going to the club and
ordering like my one of my first drinks
and for me like i'm not a huge like
alcohol guy
so like i when i went there i was like
give me the most delicious drink that
you have sir
please and he was like uh all right i
got this i was like no that sounds like
a mandrake i'm talking about give me the
girliest dress
shirley temple sold the temple exactly i
think he actually did make me a shirley
temple i don't know i forget what it was
but it was delicious and it was in one
of those
little uh you know those triangle cups
so i was walking around
sipping my drink and people are like
empty why are you drink like why don't
you just have a beer i was like
listen you guys are drinking your your
piss water beer i'm drinking my
delicious
whatever this is morning and i got
pretty [ __ ] up
i was uh pretty somewhat drunk after a
couple of those because those uh oh yeah
the drinks that taste good are the ones
you have to look out for because you
just down those
down yeah they're sneaky sneaky and then
um i woke up in kansas the next day
so that was i'm just kidding
but in fair you went to college in
kansas so that wasn't that bad right no
no no no i didn't die no i was in
massachusetts
oh okay all right okay that would be
weird yeah so that's not as cool as your
story but that's
just a funny thing that happened it's
like oh people are judging me for my you
know martini whatever who cares
that sounds like a true zemo story that
you had i'm
impressed and i was uh dancing uh just
as good as zebo
uh probably oh i'm sure you were oh yes
of course you were several
people were hurt um while i was
attempting to dance oh
but that's how you know you're doing it
right and that is it for this episode of
big question thank you so much to eric
for joining me this episode follow him
at eavos all over social media and then
follow me
at mastertainment as well and follow new
rockstars and subscribe to us on youtube
for amazing shows like fitness origins
that my boy eric
is on and he's killing it but tommy beck
i mean philip molina hosts and it is
amazing
please go watch that it's such a fun
time
tommy rocked it on the last video with
that hammer challenge good guy
yeah yeah yeah but spoilers i want the
spoilers oh yeah just to wait just to
wait till
uh well actually by the time this comes
out i think the next one will go out too
yeah yeah but that dance battle oh then
anyways yes subscribe to new rockstars
here on youtube and then hit that
notification bell so you can get all the
notifications for whenever we upload our
amazing videos here on the channel and
just take it easy everyone stay safe
and stay safe out there call your
parents maybe because thank you yes
call them we love you they talk to us
all the time like we're best friends
with them
and they have some concerns but they
love you yes they they talk to us they
say they
they told us to tell you to call them
because they just they miss you
so just do that please all right
[Music]
so
[Music]